this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to another
episode of the minimalist podcast my
name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists well does anyone
feel like this year has shed a light on
their previously unknown
excess do you feel like you've
simplified but your home is still
overstuffed you're not alone and today
we're going to talk about stuff yeah man
and
why so many of us still still have
so much of it you know i thought mariah
and i
were pretty clutter free and we are but
we started we watched uh
that season of hoarders that they have
on netflix okay
and i was like mariah we are hoarders
this is during the pandemic and uh yeah
why did you feel i mean because clearly
like
they are you know real hoarders who have
a
the clinical hoarding is a form of ocd
right which i have ocd
and and you don't have that but you
looked around and
you just saw well man i spent so much
time at home
lately i have i'm not using some of this
stuff just creeps in man
yeah uh it started with the books so
we have a lot of guests on the show we
invite some friends they have books they
send us books
autographed copies yeah and i you know
when i get one i'll put it on my
bookshelf and i've got room for it it's
not like
i had books overflowing yeah but i was
just looking at those books i'm like
i've already read that uh-huh i'm not
gonna read that uh-huh
and yeah so i got you know we've got two
rows of
books and i just got rid of one row and
now we just have an empty row but that
feels so much better
than having a row of books that i know
mariah and i are never going to read
um and then there's like a weird
pressure there right and i think that i
think you can map that on to the rest of
our stuff too
when you feel that pressure of man i
feel like i have to do something with
that with a book it's like oh i have to
commit five to nine hours
of of my time to read this thing yeah
and so in a way you just cleared out
like a hundred hours of
uh of yeah freed up a hundred hours of
free time yeah
and i think you could you could look at
other things like that as well right
yeah for sure man and then it went to my
clothes
uh so i bought i got some new shirts so
i knew these six black shirts are too
much i need to get rid of three of them
well the problem is i bought because of
my uh you know i
hadn't bought new t-shirts in two or
three years so they were fading
and i was like oh i need to get some
nice like crisp black shirts
so i had all these leftover faded shirts
and i went into my old well if i'm ever
gonna paint
i need to have a shirt that i can mess
up if i ever do yard work
i don't even have a yard
[Laughter]
what would do balcony work i kept three
of the old ones um
because like i'll work out on those and
plus they're sentimental and nice
right exactly and then we filmed our
last special in one of these shirts
and then i auctioned off the rest they
were signed black t-shirts
you signed them in black i signed your
name oh thanks yeah and black shirt for
sharpie yeah
black sherpy like a sheep
so um yeah bex and i you know we'll get
to some voicemail questions we have here
from the audience but
bex and i we don't have ella this week
and so we were that's the best time to
get rid of ella's stuff is when she's
not around
because you know she's seven so it's not
really her stuff we own it and we
lend it out to her and i don't know i
feel about that i mean
i guess given her the option she would
just hang on to everything well
sure i mean in fact most of the time we
have her go
it's just a much more tedious exercise
when we have her go through it
so we do this usually about once a month
with her and have her get rid of things
she's no longer using
but you're right she does hold on to
some things and and so i think it's a
better exercise to continuously do it
with her
but we got into the the mode of sort of
late spring
cleaning summer cleaning yeah i guess
and with the pandemic who knows are
their seasons plus we're in los angeles
there's definitely not real seasons here
right and so we're going through some of
her things it was mostly backs going
through the things and the 90-90 rule
applied perfectly to
all of this stuff there were there were
puzzles she told us a few
months ago i don't even like puzzles
anymore it's like okay well then
these puzzles are gone right and um
it was an incredible free incredibly
freeing
feeling of you her room was already
super tidy and clean you've been there
several times and and you've seen like
but it's just getting the excess away
the things that are no longer there
and making room for the things she
actually enjoys playing with
and i know because we've done this
before when she returns to
the things now she experiences she she
she's a very sort of um
she gets sensory overload very easily
and so like
i know this will will free up the the
space so that she's no longer
feeling the sort of mental clutter the
anxiety associated with
with all of these things now of course i
wouldn't get rid of anything
that i felt like she was going to use or
or enjoy
right but we we made a conscious effort
to
to get rid of the things that were no
longer serving a purpose for her that
makes sense like you're not getting rid
of something
because you think to yourself oh she
doesn't need that like you're getting
rid of stuff that
you're pretty aware of that she thinks
she doesn't need that yeah and things
we've even talked about before yeah it
was just
instead of going through the things
slowly with her it was an opportunity to
spend an hour and get rid of things that
she didn't
need just imagining like people
listening to this they're going to go to
their partner's closet
i imagined you didn't need these five
pairs of shoes
right and and so i think it's it's
probably good to talk about different
with kids
it's absolutely different with kids and
and yeah obviously i don't think it's
ever a good idea to get rid of someone
else's stuff and in fact we can we could
talk about that a bit
today the because quite often the
question that comes up and i don't know
if this is any of the questions we're
going to answer today but the question
that comes up it usually manifests in a
hey i've simplified my life and now my
wife
husband brother sister mother daughter
whoever has
too much stuff yeah in my eyes right and
how do i help them get rid of it without
having a difficult conversation it's
like well
that's impossible right and it's going
to no one said this is going to be an
easy
and easy process right and also ryan and
i aren't
out here to proselytize and try to get
you to convert someone else to
minimalism
the best thing that i i've been able to
do is show the benefits of simplifying
so that other people want to latch onto
those benefits because
if they just see you getting rid of
stuff that's not a benefit in and of
itself right away
it can be oh look that shelf is is no
longer clutter
it's easier to clean or whatever but
even those are separate benefits from
just getting rid of the stuff yeah you
know the only thing that bothers me now
is i have a box of
donations in my in the back of my car
that i don't know what to do with
because good i went to goodwill
oh yeah to try and donate a box of stuff
and the line was just wrapped around the
block
and it was funny because when i got
there i got out of the car
well first off pulling into the parking
lot it was just like packed with cars
and there wasn't
what i thought was an attendant who was
like waving me into a spot
and i pull in the spot and it's handicap
i'm like that's weird why is he telling
me to park in a handicap spot i'm like
well he's the attendant he knows what
he's doing right
and then i get out of my car and he's
like hey what kind of stuff do you have
and i'm like uh what do you mean he's
like do you have any clothes and then
i'm
starting to find out like this guy is
just hanging out in front of goodwill
and there's
actually a crowd of a crowd of like you
know a handful of people six people
hanging out who are doing exactly what
he's doing trying to like get the box of
stuff before someone donates it to
goodwill
and i actually thought about doing that
because like i said when i went up there
i realized
the line which i thought was people to
get in to shop was actually people
waiting to donate
and i just didn't have the time to wait
45 minutes or an hour in line to donate
a box of goods
wrapped around the blocks yeah donate
wow it was crazy dude and then
and this is well this is downtown
hollywood too so yeah um
you know i don't know if that makes a
difference i i have never seen a
goodwill this busy
especially for donations right um but i
imagine a lot of people are doing what
we're doing during the pandemic
yes they're like oh this is a good time
for me to declutter
so anyway i felt bad because like i did
want to give you know i want
those items to go to a good home but
like giving them
to the dudes hanging out in front of
goodwill
they would take what they wanted and
then just set the rest of the box on the
ground and i know that because
on vine street where the goodwill is
it's just like littered with
exactly what you would think people
donate to goodwill clothes and
toasters and microwaves and like the
most random stuff man
so and you didn't want your stuff to end
up on vine street right
and actually i think we got we have a
question about how to kind of get rid of
stuff
okay when we don't know what to do with
it yeah we'll we'll get into that in in
a moment i'm also reminded of this essay
the most recent thing decluttered which
is on our website
came out this spring you know that if
you're on our email list we send it out
to our
simple sunday emails and it's really
short but
i thought i'd bring it up here on the
podcast every spring
is a rebirth of sorts a natural time to
let go
start anew this is doubly true during a
pandemic
smell the flowers through your face mask
let go of excess while holding on to
your sanity
this week ryan told me about some of the
things he has decluttered so far this
year
christmas lights three shirts an
inversion table
you got rid of your inversion table yes
even as
the minimalists we're still letting go
today i tossed some ill-fitting shorts
in my donation bag last week a jacket a
pair of pants
two potted plants last month a few
kitchen utensils that didn't adhere to
my rules
how about you text an emoji of the most
recent thing you decluttered to
937-202-4654 get creative
those texts go straight to both of our
phones
and we respond to as many as we can a
few texts we'll also add you our
monday morning minimal maxims which i
just sent one out this this morning
um i've i've really liked this
experiment because a lot of people have
gotten very creative with the letting go
but it's almost been a way for them to
add an accountability partner who won't
judge them so people are letting go and
it's like they got rid of a pair of
jeans they just text emoji of the pair
of jeans to
that that phone number that goes to both
of our phones and
the the thing that i like is is
it's not anonymous but it's also not
it's not judgmental whereas you can be
anonymous on the internet and still get
judged
right here it's like ryan and i all we
do is we identify with you
yeah we're not trying to to tell you
what you need to get rid of
or that you should get rid of anything
and that
if you're happy with your status quo and
all the stuff in your house
great i just know a lot of us are
discontented
and the things are actually getting in
the way of living a more meaningful life
and that's what we want to talk about
today we've got a voicemail here from
katya in modesto california i don't have
any problem
getting rid of stuff on daily basis i
find myself
you know going out donating you know
finding another place of stuff
that i don't need or that doesn't bring
me joy
the problem is with the stuff that
brings me joy
once i find something that brings me joy
i feel like i have to have it
in every single color you know like
i i get out of control in that part
i feel like i'm i get lost from my way
of going to minimalist
in the part of finding joy in things
because i find joy in a lot of things
i don't know what i should do ryan i
think
katya might be confusing joy with
happiness not not even pleasure like you
you might get pleasure from these things
and you buy something you get the
immediate dopamine rush and
when you you reach the checkout line
there's a whole experience and retailers
are really good at creating that
experience with
muzak and aesthetics and and even they
some places even pump smells into
their their stores there's a muzak for
smells
i know because i looked into it for our
retail stores it blew my mind man
and and uh lexus does this apparently at
least they did at one point with um
chocolate chip cookies that's why it
always smelled like chocolate chip
cookies there wow
and i know because i had several lexuses
and and so they would pump smells into
their i think they had several chocolate
chip cookies
no they didn't have any there i was very
frustrated that's hilarious uh
and and so yes uh
we we have this whole experiences
created that
gives us pleasure but beyond that i
think we can
get some happiness from our things
because they augment our experience of
life and so
buying the thing that that enhances
your life that makes your life simpler
which is a bit quixotic we have to be
very careful with buying things to make
our life simpler right
but to make life more enjoyable yes
sometimes it takes accessories to do
that right
we have these microphones it's much
better that we have these microphones
than if we
didn't yeah uh we would have to go
outside and start shouting on hollywood
boulevard and we then
um we'd just be in the box and we would
just be with all the other people
right on hollywood boulevard shouting
nonsense instead we're
just on uh apple podcast shouting right
and with everyone else
with the 900 000 podcasts that are out
there and anyway
so yes things can bring you
pleasure they can bring you happiness
or at least augment your experience of
life that will
ultimately result in happiness but
i don't know that things specifically
will bring you joy in the way that she
the cathy is using this this word and so
i think things can bring you joy
only insofar as they enhance your
relationship with
other people i believe that joy happens
is only experienced with respect to
others whether it's directly a direct
experience with someone else
or indirectly you can indirectly
experience joy
through other people and so um i i think
maybe
i know that sounds trivial here but i
would change my language a little bit
because i don't think the things are
actually bringing you joy and in fact i
think
because you're calling and asking this
question they may be getting in the way
of your joy yeah i mean she used the
word out of control
yes that being out of control does not
feel joyful
right exactly in fact i i think
uh an out of control life is is a life
that
this sort of puts up a barrier against
joy in a way
and and what i would what i would look
to do here if i'm in
kathy's situation is
i would look to see how much is enough
because quite often we don't ask that
question because we got joy from one
thing
there's of course this concept of
diminishing returns
we know that if we eat one ice cream
cone it's delicious
but the second one isn't nearly as good
as the first
and i know as a former very very fat kid
i used to eat the whole box of ice cream
sandwiches
like if we got a box of eight or ten ice
cream sandwiches
you've done this before right yeah dude
i would need all 10 of them
oh man and was i getting joy out of that
last one
well no i wasn't getting joy from any of
them unless i was sharing that
experience with someone it was
gluttonous
and even that first one it brought me
pleasure
and and i would argue probably not even
happiness there's no
real nutrition in that right and and so
it brought me a pleasure but by the
tenth one it
was almost an obligation it's like
you're chasing
yes chasing that first ice cream
sandwich feeling
there's actually even studies that show
uh with that
the first bite is the best bite and the
second bite isn't as good as the first
bite
yeah and so on and so forth um you know
let alone having 10 ice cream sandwiches
you know when i hear katya here uh
i hear her saying that she likes variety
and
i think variety is important in life um
whether it's with your clothes or
whether it's with uh relationships or
you know the entertainment you're taking
i mean variety is something we all crave
yes but yeah i totally agree like she
has to
figure out what's enough or another way
uh
to look at that is she needs to create
some friction for herself
and deciding what enough is that's
that's you know some friction to be like
oh okay like
i like those those shoes uh
maybe i'll get a second pair because
we're not against having two different
colors of shoes
right uh but we're just having three
different colors exactly
well you know i'd be interested to hear
what you have to say
um with your jackets yeah because i know
how
you know you've talked before about how
you're not very minimalist with jackets
right
so how do you how do you call me a
jacket slap a jacket [ __ ] yes
you are a you are a jacket [ __ ] how do
you
um how do you create friction with your
jackets yeah
yeah so so i i do have a million jackets
no i have nine if you're rounding up to
the nearest i counted them although i
got rid of one recently so i guess i
have eight now
minimalist but if i were to bring
another one in at this point
so these are eight jackets that i all
use they all fit so here's how i create
the friction and i'll i'll finish
answering your question
somewhat indirectly as well but here's
the direct answer is
i have rules around it right it's a
90-90 rule have i used
this in the last 90 days will i use this
in the next 90 and so
katya go ahead and download our it's a
free ebook it's called the minimalist
rule book 16 rules for living
with less and i would encourage you to
download that at our website the
minimalists.com
rulebook because that rule is in there
ryan
when we're talking about the 90-90 rule
um
it's it's in the book we call it the
seasonality rule because it accounts for
functionally all seasons if i go back 90
days that is
spring right and i go forward 90 days
it's it's
it's fall and if you live somewhere in
the in the winter you might need to say
well
it depends on what time of year we're in
a bad time of year for the 90 90 rule
but
even now it's still it still works most
of the time yeah because
if something works in the fall it also
works in the spring and vice versa
really what i'm trying to figure out is
is this going to work in three seasons
for me is it going to work
in summer fall and winter and
have i used it in that time frame if not
am i going to use it
in the next 90 days if not then i give
myself permission to let go so i did
that with some of ella's toys this past
week because we already discussed
i do that with my clothes uh and and
recently i've gained a little bit of
weight because i've been exercising and
lifting weights and so my
hands beefing up yeah my i have really
skinny bird legs
and they're just less bird-like right
now and so a lot of my pants don't fit
anymore
so i had to buy new pants recently and
in doing that i obviously got rid of
the old ones in the process and because
those are no longer going to continue to
serve our purpose i know i'm not going
to wear them in the next 90 days and so
i give myself permission to let go i
think that creates some friction but let
me
let me just add to it with by saying
this ryan
if ella she i don't want her to have no
toys just like i don't want katya to
have
no collectibles yeah you may get some
pleasure or just like one color of
of of of her work in her wardrobe i mean
yeah
right and so so i want i want ella to be
able to have toys that enhance
her life that she will enjoy and
hopefully she can get joy out of because
she shares the experience with other
people those are the best toys by the
way yeah the ones she's able to
share that experience with guns yes
exactly she loves shooting me with that
i imagine she loves shooting everyone
with that well she hates getting shot
with it herself though yeah she does
she cannot she can dish it out but she
can't take it yeah um
yeah i'll run into a room with both of
them let let go on her that's great
uh and anyway so but so nerf guns are a
good example
her having a couple of those is great
now what if i bought her
14 of them right what's she gonna do
with them yeah
they're actually going to get in the way
of the experience
because it adds several layers of
complexity it adds in the paradox of
choice
it adds in additional clutter it adds in
things that we don't actually
use and thus we don't get to experience
them
if you have things that you're not
experiencing
whether it's a piece of art on the wall
if you were to put a sheet over that
piece of art that's no longer
experiencing it
or it's a tool like a nerf gun if you're
not
using that to enhance the experiences in
your life then it's probably just
getting in the way
yeah yeah i mean when if i was katya i
would ask myself when i'm looking at all
the different colors of something and
all the different
you know versions of whatever it is i
would ask myself also like what
am i getting these different versions
for is it um
you know because what's the why behind
right because often like i'll get
something
where i'm like oh you know i'll i'll
wear this at a funeral one day like
that's how i used to think when i bought
stuff
you buy your entire wardrobe planning
for funerals right exactly exactly
uh but no it's it's interesting because
you can get caught in that trap of
you you find an excuse to purchase
something for uh
just in case and maybe you talk yourself
into it just for when
um but i think if katya creates some
rules for herself creates a little bit
of friction and
asks herself why is she buying those
things like maybe
it will help her make better decisions i
like this because and we'll end with
this the the why
you often will it'll lead you to deeper
wise and so
why are you buying this well because
they get joy from it okay rea
and maybe it asks you to make makes you
ask another question like am i really
getting joy from it how am i getting joy
from it
why do i get joy from it is there
another way or a better way to get
joy than by purchasing more widgets
and if the answer is no this is really
enhancing my life i really need to
purchase this
life jacket for when i'm going uh
tubing or whatever like then that's
that's totally fine if it's the best use
of your resources
then great i don't want you to live
without stuff i don't want you to live
without beauty either
but i do want you to start to question
those things that are in your life right
now or
in kathy's case the things you're
thinking about bringing in
because we mistake pleasure for joy
and in the long run those 10 ice cream
sandwiches are going to do the
opposite for me they're going to they're
going to get in the way of my joy
because they're going to make me fat
they're going to make me unhealthy
they're going to make me actually
malnourished and i think right now we
are
malnourished by our things yeah
well katya let me send you a couple of
tour tickets we're going on tour
uh and we're gonna be in a couple cities
near you near
modesto you're in between sort of close
to san francisco and sacramento
whichever one
is more convenient for you katya we'll
send you a couple tickets sean if you
could reach out to her i'd appreciate
that and
if you are listening to this at home and
you want to check out any of our tour
dates it's just the minimalists.com
tour we do a live version of the podcast
we often have special guests
podcast guests musical guests ryan will
do his juggling act
my dubstep routine it's amazing
uh yeah minimalists.com tor also enjoy
that minimalist rule book there are 16
rules
for living with less in there ryan
mentioned a few of them the just in case
rule the just for win rule
the emergency item rule would be another
one that stands out the seasonality rule
and a bunch of other rules that i think
will help you set up the boundaries
you need to be more intentional with
your stuff and it's free
on our website rasheed from
massachusetts has a question for us
i'm active duty military and i transfer
every
four to five years you ever take i've
had so many things in storage that
i've wanted to keep because they
actually do mean something to me
putting them in a house short term i
don't really get to put them where i
want them
or how like eventually when i retire
from my house to be set up
how do i mitigate that i don't want to
buy storage
but i also don't want to get rid of it
but there's only so many things i can
hold on to without just cluttering
everything basically
mementos that i'll put up on the wall
eventually in my actual retirement home
what's the best way to go about that so
ryan sounds to me like rasheed
he's facing two problems he says i i
don't want to get storage but i also
don't want to get rid of it
and so they're just sort of sitting
there in the way right now the the
things that he has
yeah i know you have an experience with
with storage yeah when i
uh when i sold my condo or when i moved
out of my condo i should say because i
didn't sell it i rented it out at first
didn't sell until a couple years later
we left in ohio we went to montana yeah
well yeah well actually it was before
we went to montana so when i when i was
simplifying getting rid of debt i rented
out my condo
uh so i didn't have that debt payment
and then i moved into a place that was
like you know 350 bucks a month or
something
you were the most available resident in
pickwell ohio that's right it was a very
small
apartment and i did not have room for my
washer and dryer i didn't have room
for the couches i had and the the lazy
boy that i had
and i had like this antique chair so um
it was all stuff that i very much
enjoyed
and that i liked having in my house and
i was like oh i am i'm going to find a
home for this stuff eventually
um so temporarily i'm going to have this
in a storage unit just to
uh just to hang on to until i move into
another place well it turns out that
other place was montana
yeah and when that happened i was like
oh
like this is not this isn't gonna work
um i have to
i have to get rid of this stuff because
i'm not gonna bring it out to montana
with me
so uh the reason why i'm telling the
story rasheed is because
you know i had an absolutely you know
decent reason
to have a storage unit for a little bit
the uh the lease that i signed on that
apartment was only six months
so i gave myself six months to have this
storage unit in piccolo ohio is like 30
bucks a month so it's 180 so hold on to
this stuff yeah
um i mean it turns out i wasted 180
bucks
but but but i i had these these barriers
or these rules set up
to to follow for the stuff in my storage
unit so rasheed
um give yourself an end date um uh
if it's if it's sentimental stuff i
understand like i had that antique chair
that i had that i know i've talked about
before
i paid 450 for it i ended up selling it
for 40 i had like a storage unit
um garage sale and like people just
showed up in my storage unit and
you know it made me offers on stuff um
but yeah that cherry end up selling for
forty dollars but for me
i had to get rid of it so someone
offered me 40 bucks and yeah i wish i
could have got more out of it but
you know i couldn't so i cost at that
point yeah i took what i took what i
could get
it's worth whatever someone's willing to
pay for it and there are some items
it was worth more to you because you it
had a sort of sentimental value yeah
right
oh yeah i would also ask rasheed too
though like if he's holding on to stuff
because of the cost
like my washer and dryer i was like oh
you know i spent 800
on this set um it's worth me you know 30
bucks for six months to hold on to these
um
but you know at two years or three years
i might as well just buy a new washer
and dryer so i think rashid has to look
at that too
um if it's sentimental stuff yeah like
that's a little bit more difficult to
get through but if it's just stuff
you're holding on to because you don't
want to purchase again
you know look at how much you're
actually spending on the storage unit
versus
you know what it would take to replace
those things yeah well that i think
that's a great point and so there are
some things he says that they have
a particular meaning to him and i just
want to be clear
things none of our things have an
intrinsic meaning
they have only the meaning we assign to
them i'm not saying it's
wrong to assign meaning to certain
things but when
everything is precious nothing is
precious
absolutely and so keep that in mind when
we have 300 000 items in our home
and we treat it as though they're all
the same what we're really doing
is we're saying the really important
things aren't that important
and so i think maybe one of the things
rasheed that you can do just to add on
to what ryan said because i i completely
agree with everything he said there
i i would say that yes they might mean
something to you but if you go back to
why do they mean
something to you and i can tell you what
i did with my mom's stuff
the sentimental items in particular i
kept some of the things
but instead of watering them down with
dozens or hundreds or thousands of
of sentimental trinkets i kept a handful
of
sentimental things and i get far more
value from those few things i kept
than if if i just had hundreds of them
and
and so i don't i also don't like the
binary choice here of
storage or get rid of everything right
uh and
i think what you can do is you can take
photos i did this with a lot of my mom's
possessions as well i took photos of the
things i didn't want to hold on to
so i wasn't getting rid of the memories
because the memories aren't in the
things
but i was able to trigger those memories
and i still have photos of many of her
things if i want to be able to trigger
those memories now occasionally there's
a tactile thing
that we need to hold on to to trigger a
memory that's usually not the case i
know people bring that up all the time
i personally i maybe you can leave a
comment on youtube if you disagree with
me or call in
and leave a comment send a voice memo
podcast at theminimalists.com
and let me know if i'm wrong here but i
don't know of anything
that i've needed to hold on to for the
tactile experience that i couldn't
get out of taking a photo of that thing
that i was no longer going to use now
the storage
it might be the price of admission and
so i think that
we have to think of you know when you
when you go to a concert ride you have
to pay the price
of admission whatever that is and if
it's a bob dylan concert
um may he rest in peace he's still alive
oh yeah his new album's pretty good
actually uh yeah
and uh but if you if you uh
want to go to bob dylan costa and it's
250 bucks to get in
you have to be willing to pay the price
of admission right
the same is true with the stuff you're
if you want to hold on to the stuff
the price of admission is you're going
to have to either
clutter your home with it that's a high
cost to me that's not a cost
i'm willing to pay or you're gonna have
to store it for a period of time
rasheed unfortunately it sounds to me
like you got a while for retirement
let's say you're 15 years away from
retirement yeah
are you going to pay 15 years of storage
do the math on that
and if so just know that's the price of
admission
that's the price you're willing to pay
to hold on to these things
that supposedly have meaning or what is
what's the third path right
there's the the left path and the right
path but you don't recognize like maybe
there's a
separate path and that path is a
combination of the two
maybe you can hold on to a few of the
things get
more sentimental value from the few
things you hold on to
have some sort of of barrier a boundary
it could be
a one one sort of trunk or chest
that carries your sentimental items and
it can never go beyond
the limits of that trunk or chest maybe
it's even a beautiful
trunk that you keep in your house and
now you have this piece of artwork that
holds your sentimental items
you're not paying for a storage locker
but also you're not cluttering your
space
with the excess stuff because if it
doesn't fit in there you give yourself
permission
to let it go yeah rasheed you've got a
tough decision and as much as i wish
that josh and i could make this for you
it's up to you
if you want to know what josh and i
would do neither of us would hold on to
something for
you know 15 years and pay for a storage
unit just so we could have it one day
in this hypothetical retirement future
rashida i want to give you a copy of
our book everything that remains it's
it's really the story about
dealing with sentimental items i mean i
think that's at the core of the book is
is is we treat everything as sentimental
and so much so that we don't even know
how to get the
momentum we need to let go of the things
in our life and so
everything that remains is a story of
ryan and i the sort of transformation
from these suit and tie corporate guys
to becoming minimalists and eventually
the minimalists
and and that that entire journey over
over a five-year period
and i think you'll find a lot of value
in the stories it's my favorite thing
that we've
ever created so far uh and if you like
our podcast you'll like the audiobook
version
of everything that remains or if you
want the book book or the ebook
version we're happy to send those to you
as well ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it is time for our
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text
your questions to
five 937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts
go to both of our phones and we reply to
as many as we can personally
and we even reply to some on the podcast
like we're about to do right now now
during the lightning round this is where
ryan and i do our best to answer every
question
with a short shareable less than 140
character response and we put the text
to your
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share or pick the answers
on social media if you'd like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place minimalmaxims.com
all right our question here is from cara
some of my stuff is broken
or worn out and i would like to dispose
of it responsibly
how do you dispose of stuff that no
longer has a useful
life well i'll give you my pithy answer
it's not a direct
answer to her so i'll try to give her an
answer as well i just like this as a
as a tweetable answer here the most
sustainable purchase
is left on the shelf i think quite often
we we get caught up in in buying the
most
eco-friendly thing but the eco-friendly
isst option
is to not bring it home with you in the
first place now we that's not
something we can always do but realize
there's always that third option if
you're trying to
choose between widget a and widget b
option c is you don't maybe maybe
you don't need it at all now cara is
also in
in a place where okay she has some stuff
she needs to get rid of so i think you
have something pithy for
yeah uh my fifth answer is this it's
hard to be joyful in a home
that mimics a landfill and what i see
often
is people holding on to things because
like oh well like i see this with uh
zero waste where they're like oh i got
these light bulbs i don't know what to
do with i got these
uh you know batteries that i don't know
what to do with
um it takes some stuff it takes work to
get rid of responsibly
yeah so like when it comes to batteries
when it comes to laptops uh you can go
to best buy you can recycle them there
there are other recycling programs
but it takes some work but if you're
just hanging onto stuff
because you don't know how to dispose of
it yeah then you're treating your house
like a landfill and that's going to
bring you
a lot of discontent so uh you know
you've got to do some work and find out
how to if you got nuclear waste at your
home
yeah that's hard to get rid of but
there's a proper way to get rid of it
yeah and i think it's going to take some
work so i have a 30 day rule on this
where
i will give myself 30 days to try to
sell the thing so if i have something
that i can sell because i think that's
one of the most responsible ways to get
rid of something is
let someone else who's going to get
value from the thing use it yeah if i
can't sell it
then i will try to donate it after after
30 days if it's something i'm not able
to donate
then i will eventually you know either
try to recycle it
or have to throw it away depending on
what the item is
and no one wants to fill a landfill up i
mean right we all can agree that
landfills suck
um if you've ever been to a landfill i
mean it's one of the most depressing
sites
i will say however putting something in
a landfill
uh that isn't gonna seep into the ground
isn't gonna seep chemicals into the
ground and ruin
you know fresh water and stuff that
actually is
even though it's a crappy way it's the
best way to dispose of something
because it'll decompose faster in the
landfill than if it's just sitting in
your house yeah and you're it's better
in a landfill than in your living room
yeah oh it's tweetable i think
nice all right before we get into our
listener tips ryan we've got some good
ones today also
an added value segment that i'm actually
sad about ryan oh
i'm uh there's a tear in my eye
metaphorically
uh before we get to that though ryan we
have a bunch more surprise questions
this week like
how do you let go when you're
overwhelmed by decluttering
that's where i started i was overwhelmed
because i had so much stuff and i was
already organized
i felt decluttered but i wasn't
decluttered so we're gonna get into that
also where do you draw the line for
sentimental items what is sentimental
what isn't
what stuff do people own that you find
to be absolutely
unnecessary ryan we're going to tell
some people to get rid of some stuff
or else what does marie kondo
wait uh does marie condo own too much
stuff a lot of these marie condo
questions coming up i know it's pretty
cool
i think what happened is we answered one
or two and now the people
yeah so does marie condo own too much
stuff find out
also is minimalism dying several
articles about that have come out
recently
we'll talk about that also try these
seven tips to help pare down
plus a million more questions about
excess stuff for the minimalists
and if you want to hear all that check
out our maximal episodes on
the minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast by the way
and it's just a couple bucks and it is
the most honest way for the minimalist
to earn an income because we don't
believe
in ads so we make money if and only if
you find value in
and support what we create head on over
to theminimalists.com
support and subscribe uh right there
you'll be able to subscribe to get a
personal link so that our private
podcast episodes play
in your favorite podcast app app app
they knew what you meant yeah i think
they got it all right ryan what else you
got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hello josh and ryan my name is melissa
hollingsworth i'm actually from dayton
ohio i wanted to provide um input to the
question that brandy had in
las vegas regarding her yearbooks her
hometown library may
also accept her yearbooks where i live
in dayton and they just recently
rebuilt the downtown metro library
they're actually building a database for
all the local year
books just to provide an example
hello i am colleen and i am from the
netherlands
recently i heard a podcast that was
about
giving presents or receiving presents
and i wanted to share some
nice ideas about that so
every year it's normal with your
birthday that you ask for presents
but if you say no i don't want to have
anything people still come up with stuff
and so this year i tried to ask everyone
for one flower
a picked flower or a bod flower didn't
matter just one flower so
at the end of the evening i had one
bouquet of
beautiful flowers and it was very nice
because
everyone was talking about how nice the
bouquet was
so it really added some value to the
evening as well
and other ideas i i haven't tried them
yet but i also wanted to try
maybe next year to ask people to give
food that i would donate
to well we called the food bank
or i could in holland is very common
that you make an online list
where you put on the things that you
want to have
and i was thinking about instead of
putting things on the list
i would write down things like
a smile or a compliment or a good story
or a funny joke or something like that
so
that will be their present for the
evening and i think that would be a nice
idea to try out and then
um for when it comes to giving gifts i
have a few friends that
also said i don't want anything and
now for three times in a row i've
succeeded in
actually not giving something because
they ask for nothing
and it's interesting because it did make
me feel very uncomfortable
and because it's in our culture to give
something
um so but they
didn't they said i don't want anything
so i didn't give them anything i just
gave them my company and
in the end it felt good um so i think if
someone really asked for nothing then
just
don't give anything just give your
company or a smile
or otherwise just give a nice flower
everyone
gets happy from a nice flower all right
joe for our added value this week
ryan uh you have been there at least
once maybe twice
the annenberg space for photography over
in century city have i been there
yeah you definitely went there with us
yeah we did you see the walls
yes or was it i think it was the animals
one the uh
okay yeah yeah the endangered species
yeah so that one was called um
oh i'm blanking on the name but then so
it's the honestly it's what a photo
museum should be
it's it is the best photo museum i've
ever been in by far
it's not even there's not even a close
second it's gorgeous it's
it's the parking is was free there the
admission was free
in fact parking in century city is like
30 bucks anytime you go there they
validate your park and give it to you
for free
and the the the way they curated
photographs was just amazing it's just
the right size
and then they would show like a 20
minute documentary of whatever exhibit
was going on at the time
so we went there once they had this one
about since there's a lot of talk about
building a wall
over the last three or four years that
they've they did a sort of history of
wall building like great wall
china the peace walls and belfast
and there's you know they say a
picture's worth a thousand words
whatever but
but a a great picture especially a
series of pictures
they tell a story in a way that is i it
was just so profound
and then they would they would do a
documentary about the the the whole
collection
and it was it was fascinating it was so
well curated
well during covid they have closed down
and they're done they're they're not
opening back up no yeah
they're like they're done closed down
indefinitely yeah
yeah yeah permanently and and so
i i bring that sad news because you're
never going to get to experience in
person but the second best thing is
they're
they have all their archives on their
website it's beautifully done so
sean if you would put a link in the show
notes to the annenberg space for
photography
i would definitely encourage you to
check out they did one on hip-hop it was
uh
called contact uh contact sheet i
believe oh yeah i think i
saw that one too actually yeah okay yeah
and so i i just
i really enjoyed going there and it's
it's irreplaceable
and it's sad you know we're starting to
see the victims of of
this pandemic and some of them i i feel
less bad about it's a lot of the retail
because the retail it's just
accelerating
i think what's gonna happen with retail
is
we're ended up in 2030 right now instead
of 2020 retail wise
it just took the the last 10 years and
and contracted it into like a six months
span yeah and unfortunately
we're going to see these these other
these other spaces
like this annenberg space for
photography it's
it's gone now but you can still find it
online and i would encourage you to
check it out in the show notes it's
the just the stories that are told
through the photographs there
and i'm in fact the nice thing that they
have that on there is there are plenty
of exhibits i didn't get to see before
we ever
moved to la it's been there for 10 years
and so there's 10 years worth of
archives i get to go back and experience
not the same as being in person but at
least it's there to experience online
awesome i would encourage you to check
it out and real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalist now
ryan
it's a new month ahead i think it's in a
couple days from now
uh brand new month which means a brand
new
30-day minimalism game yeah we have a
free calendar on our website
it's the minimalists.com game now some
of you might be saying well what the
heck is the 30 day minimalism game well
it's the most popular
thing that i think we've ever done in
terms of a challenge or anything like
that
you can download the free calendar now
which is great because you can sort of
play along and
it tells you how many items you get rid
of that day and how many you've gotten
rid of so far it kind of does the math
for you
you want to talk about what the
minimalism game is yeah specifically
yeah you find a friend or family member
or an arch enemy
and you agree to play this game with
each other where you both get rid of one
item on the first day of the month and
then on the second day of the month you
get rid of two items and then on the
third day of the month three items so
forth and so on right
whoever lasts the longest wins is that
what you tell
mariah i do all the time
uh it's real easy that first week or so
right but then you get to like day
18 you gotta get rid of 18 things and
then day 19 you got your
got to get rid of 19 things so uh you
know if you both make it though you both
win
yeah um but maybe put up a bet like you
know someone makes dinner or
takes you out well i guess you can't
really go out these days to restaurants
but
uh yeah josh and i josh i usually bet a
dollar on stuff
or ten thousand dollars yeah so
so yeah i i what i like about this game
is it's only twenty dollars
no it's absolutely free and uh you can
actually join there are tens of
thousands of people who share so share
your pictures on instagram
you can follow the hashtag it's hashtag
men's game like m-i-n-s
unbelievable the amount of pictures
online with that hashtag yeah and so
people
start every single month if you don't
follow us on instagram you can just you
can tag us
on there we re-share some of our
favorites on our instagram stories
every single month there are thousands
of people playing right now
uh that will link to it in the show
notes as well the minimalists.com
game download the free printable
calendar right there you just print it
up
you have it right there near your
computer and that way you know it's the
14th day of the month of course i get
rid of 14 things but there's also it
does the math for you so you already
know how many things you've gotten rid
of
which is uh it's a nice bonus because
people do the math wrong and they
they think it's uh uh it's multiples
each day
which i think you'd have to end up
getting rid of a billion things if you
doubled every day
wait a minute i don't know what the math
is but i don't think most of us would be
able to survive
yeah uh my favorite though ryan is when
people keep playing beyond day 30
yeah they're like it's day 37 of the of
the men's game
and they just keep going yeah and so you
can get together with a group of friends
co-workers whatever
uh check it out the minimalists.com game
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram
at the minimalist come to one of our
live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com
you'll also receive our simple
sunday emails each week and if you leave
here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time